- Lundi dernier, durant
la première fenêtre de lancement
de la mégafusée Artemis I,
des dizainesmimimilliers
de personnes massées
à proximité de cap Canaveral
pour assister au spectacle
sont reparties déçues.
Cinq jours plus tard, la fusée
est toujours sur le pas de tir
et la NASA se prépare
pour un nouvel essai.
L'Agence spatiale a résolu
les problèmes techniques
obésésés au début de la semaine
et la météo serait favorable.
Mais encore une fois, il faudra
se croiser les doigts.
La NASA, qui avait pris du
retard depuis la mise au rancart
des navettes spatiales, a mis
la barre très haute avec son
programme de retour à la Lune.
OLIVIER HERNANDEZ, astrophys. et
r,r,r, Planétarium Rio Tinto Aln
- Je pense qu'ils ont voulu
vraiment frapper un grand coup,
effectivement, en allant
sur la Lune pour...
parce qu'il y a cett
je dirais, cette guerre,
entre guillemets, géopolitique
qui est très, très importante,
et d'arriver à faire
les premiers quelque chose,
ça montre l'avancée
technologique d'un pays, oui.
- Artemis I, qui volera
sans équipage, est un monstre,
un appareil plus puissantquququV
du programme Apollo.
Avec ses quatre moteurs
de navette spatiale réusinés
et l'équivalent d'une piscine
olympique de carburantûûûlé
en 8 minutes, elle va atteindre
la vitesse vertigineuse
de 27 000 kilomètres à l'heure.
Une fois en orbite, on va
relâcher la capsule Orion et
son module de service européen.
Orion va d'abord rejoindre la
Lune, puis l'orbiter plusieurs
fois avant de revenir sur Terre,
37 jours plus tard, protégé par
le plus grand bouclier thermique
jamais conçu.
On prévoit lancer Artemis II,
le premier vol habité, en 2024,
avec quatre astronautes à bord,
dont un Canadien.
En parallèle, les États-Unis
et leurs partenaires vont
amorcer la construction
du Gateway, la future station
spatiale lunaire. C'est à partir
du Gateway que des navettes vont
transporter les astronautes
l l l'équipement nécessaire
pour assurer une présence
humaine permanente sur la Lune,
puis, éventuellement,
sur la planète Mars.
- On sait que le chemin
pour aller sur Mars, ce n'est
pas forcément la ligne droite,
c'est vraiment d'aller sur
la Lune et de profiter du peu
d'attraction de la gravitation
sur la Lune pour s'en servir
comme base de lancement ou base
de relais pour pouvoir aller
sur Mars.
- Mais la factsesesera salée.
À ce jour, le programme, amorcé
sous l'administration Bush,
a déjà coûté plus
de 90 milliards de dollars.
Et lncncncement d'Artemis I,
à lui seul, plus de 4 milliards.
Les Américains ne sont
également plus seuls dans
la course vers la Lune :
C C Chine est aussi
sur la ligne de départ.
La NASA devra aussi surveiller
ses arrières : la très innovante
compagnie américaine SpaceX
développe actuellement sa propre
fusée lunaire géante, Starship,
qui, contrairement à Artemis,
sera entièrement réutilisable,
donc beaucoup moins coûteuse
à opérer.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.